[موسيقى]
اعطيني قمحا اعطيك جبنا هكذا صارت الامور
قبل ان تزدهر متاجر البيع بالتجزئه مع
اصناف لا محدوده من السلع ما دعا للبحث عن
اليه لتصنيفها وتسعيرها لولا اختراع
الباركود الذي اسهم في فوتره العمليه
الشرائيه فما القصه في عام
1932 فكر والسفر
في ان يلخص فكرته حول تنظيم البيع بمحل
التجزئه في اطروحه الماجستير خاصه التي
تضمنت توزيع بطاقات مثقوبه على كل منتج ثم
يختار العاميل البطاقات المثقوبه ويقدمها
للبائع لحساب الفاتوره لكنها لم تكن فكره
عمليه ولم تنجح
بقيه الفكر نسيان حتى عام
1949 عندما مادر تاجر تجزئه بطلب ساعدت من
باحثين في معهد دراكسل الامريكي لايجاد
طريقه لقراءه معلومات السلاح ففكر طالب
دراسات العليا نور من جوزيف فود لاند
باستخدام الحبر الحساس للضوء فوق البنفسجي
وطور مع زميله برنرد سيلفر نموذجا بدائيا
ولكنه لم ينجح عمليا كما انه مكلف
فكروود لاند بطريقه شفره مورس المستخدمه
بالتلجراف التي تقوم على استخدام النقاط
والشرطات لتوصيل المعلومات فاختبر عدد من
الرسومات التي تحوي خطوطا رفيعه وسميكه
حتى نجح مع سيلفر في اختراع اول نظام
باركود حقيقيه بتقنيه التلجراف ونجح في
انجاز اول قارئه للمواد المطبوعه عام
1952 لكن التطبيق العمليه للباركود الخطي
تاخر لستينيات القرن الماضي
[موسيقى]
وكنا بامضاء اليهودي الذي كان يعمل في
شركه سيلفانا وفكر في معالجه مشكله نقل
السيارات اثناء الشحن عبر السكك الحديديه
استخدم كولينز لقراءته اله بحجم الثلاجه
لقراءه رسومات من شرائط زرقاء وبرتقاليه
تشفر تفاصيل ملكيه السياره ورقمها وعرفت
باسمه كارتراك
فكر كونان في تطوير نظام للبقالات لكن
ادارته رفض تمويل المشروع فاستقال واسس
عمله الخاص تاركا المهمه لغيره حيث اشتعال
السباق لانشاء نظام
التي كان يعمل فيها هولاند
نجحت شركه اي ار سي في انتاج تصميم جديد
عرف به رمز عين ثيران وسمي لاحقا باسم رمز
المنتج العالمي او يو بي سي الذي وصل
لذربه نجاحه عام
1981 عندما بدا الجيش الامريكي استخدامه
لتسميه معداته ثم اصبح مستخدما في العديد
من المنتجات حول العالم
تزامى اختراعه الرمز الشريطي يو بي سي مع
انخفاض تكلفه الليزر فتم العمل على تطوير
الجهاز القارئ كما توسع استخدام الباركود
في تطبيقات مختلفه وظهرت تطبيقات مرتبطه
باجهزه الهواتف النقاله ليصبح هذا
الاختراع اكثر من مجرد ارقام وشرائط تقرا
تفاصيل سلعه
[موسيقى]